chiku selects mr. Porter has been  incredible we have this idea to partner  with mr. Porter to be able to have a  platform what could be better than  pointing guys in the right direction  telling them exactly where they can buy  the things that we show in the magazine  editorially when you've got all of that  selection and that curation already done  for you and you've got it in a beautiful  hero shop is really a no-brainer the  reader can actually go and shop and find  those exact things that are the magazine  this is really an opportunity for us to  see the issue it comes to life I think  this report is getting really cool and  classy and everything GQ is so it just  feels really natural we want to make the  whole process is very simple and very  easy and give guys the confidence to go  out there and buy the cool looks that  they say in GQ